in
1875 charles darwin published a book
that would go on to shake the scientific
community to its core
some even claimed that what he published
was impossible that it was against the
order of nature as willed by god
his observations began with a peculiar
plant in the south of england
he noticed dozens of dead insects or
what remained of them adhered to the
sticky tentacles of the common sundew
plant
many plants cause the incidental death
of certain insects the horse chestnut
for example regularly kills insects that
get stuck to its protective sticky film
but darwin had a hunch that these insect
deaths were no accident he collected
specimens and began extensive
experimentation to find out if these
plants could really be catching these
insects on purpose
to trap them in order to eat them he fed
his plants salts of ammonia egg white
various insects and even small chunks of
cheese until soon he was able to
scientifically describe their digestive
systems and prove unequivocally and for
the first time that plants can indeed
eat meat
today there are over 600 species of
carnivorous plants known to science
darwin's beloved sundew plant is in the
adhesive trap category where prey
becomes stuck to extremely sticky
droplets
then there are the pitfall traps like
pitcher plants where prey falls into the
base and is digested
and then there's the suction traps like
the water wheel plant where aquatic prey
animals get sucked into a one-way trap
door but the most iconic of all
carnivorous plants are the snap traps
like the voracious and enigmatic venus
flytrap
unsuspecting prey lured by the fly
trap's sweet-smelling nectar land in the
jaws of the fly trap and quickly find
themselves locked behind the teeth of
the hungry plant where they are then
digested slowly over the course of a
week the discovery of these meat-eating
plants changed the very idea of what it
means to be a carnivore but how and why
would plants evolve such a taste for
flesh how is it possible for a leafy
green to become a deadly predator
[Music]
venus fly traps are naturally found in
only one area in the world in the
coastal plains of north and south
carolina specifically in one small
region 200 kilometers across
they are small plants that live in the
open understory of their habitat an
understory that remains open due to
natural fires that burn away the larger
shading plants
and down here amongst the marshy grass
is where their killing commences
the trap of the venus flytrap is a leaf
with two lobes connected at a hinge on
its stalk the lobes sit waiting curved
in the open position luring prey insects
with sweet smelling nectar if something
like a fly spider or beetle lands on or
crawls across the gaping jaws it risks
touching any of the fly trap's six
sensory hairs
the hairs that give the plant the signal
to snap shut
if it touches a single hair the plant
won't budge and the insect is safe for
now but a deadly timer has begun within
the plant a crucial 30 seconds that will
determine if the insect lives or dies
if the insect touches another sensory
hair within the 30-second window the
insect is doomed
upon the second touch the lobes snap
shut faster than the blink of an eye the
plant's movement is controlled by an
electrical signal created by the hairs
when a hair is bent by touch it acts as
a lever that stretches the envelopes of
cell membranes at its base
the stretching causes ion channels to
burst open
positively charged calcium ions flood
out creating an action potential aka an
electrical signal that spreads from the
hair over the entire flap trap after two
action potentials the trap snaps shut
the initially concave trap lobes move
towards each other and eventually change
to a convex state the reason it needs
two triggers within a 30 second window
is to prevent the plant from closing
erroneously and wasting energy for
something like a raindrop or a twig
but how does a plant know when 30
seconds have passed
how does a plant tell time
researchers had a hunch that it had to
do with the changes in calcium
concentrations inside the leaves
to test this they genetically modified
venous fly traps to emit green
fluorescence when calcium ions were
present in the leaf cells when the first
hair is touched a flood of green
overtakes the leaf showing a big
presence of calcium ions but as the
seconds pass the concentration slowly
starts to drop
but if a second hair is touched the
calcium concentration again increases
flooding the leaf with even more green
it's only when a certain threshold is
reached in the calcium concentration
that the trap snaps shut
this threshold can only be reached if
the two stimuli occur within 30 seconds
but the timed triggers are not the only
way a venus fly trap ensures it eats
only the things it wants
if you happen to have a pet venus fly
trap you may realize you can trigger two
hairs yourself causing it to snap shut
this may tempt you to feed it cheese
like darwin did with his sundew plants
but if you did you'd end up disappointed
you could indeed get the fly trap to
close on the cheese initially but after
a few hours it will reopen rejecting
your generous gift
that's because the plant requires
sustained wiggling within its jaws to
fully seal and begin the deadly
digesting process
this ensures it's using its digestive
resources only on hearty insect meals
but once a wriggling bug does cause the
trap to fully seal it's no longer a
mouth but a stomach
digestive juices flood into the closed
trap the ph drops dramatically and meat
digesting enzymes similar to ones in our
stomachs start to break down the trapped
creature the more the prey fights and
wriggles the more digestive enzymes are
released if you're a bug the more you
struggle the faster you die
slowly over the course of a week or so
the insect's body is liquefied and the
lining of the trap absorbs the nutrients
it's an impressive if not a bit
unsettling survival strategy and it's
hard to look at this small plant and
understand how it came to be
how do plants make the jump from getting
all their nutrients from the soil and
the sun
to luring and brutally killing living
breathing creatures
while the venus fly trap does extract
some energy from its food like we do
what it's really after when it kills
prey is not the insect's calorie content
but rather it's nitrogen plants need
nitrogen in order to successfully carry
out photosynthesis as it's a major
component of chlorophyll it's also a
major component of amino acids the
building block of proteins and is needed
for general growth and regeneration in
the plant without nitrogen a plant will
wither and die
and this could be a major problem for
plants growing where the venus flytrap
does
that particular area of the carolinas
where they live has soil that is
extremely acidic and nitrogen deficient
but this lack of nutrients is no problem
for the venus fly trap which gets
between 50 and 75 of its nitrogen from
chowing down on insects
a similar story is true for the other
carnivorous plants
pitcher plants for example grow in
marshy nutrient poor soil as does the
sun do it seems pretty clear then that
carnivory evolved in plants to cope with
nutrient scarce soils
that explains the why but how does a
plant evolve from a purely
photosynthetic life to a meat-eating one
to get to the bottom of this question
scientists examined the genomes of three
related carnivorous plants the venus fly
trap the aquatic waterwheel plant and
the sundew plant
all of these plants use motion to
capture prey and shared a common
ancestor about 70 million years ago
researchers realized that around this
time 70 million years ago these plants
common ancestor underwent a whole genome
duplication generating a second copy of
all of its dna
this duplication enabled the plants to
keep one copy of each gene with the
original function
the second copy was thus freed up to be
tinkered with where mutations could be
tolerated
eventually these additional gene copies
could start to mutate in a way to
fulfill an entirely new role
for example plants typically produce
enzymes that break down a polymer called
chitin as a defense against fungi but
with a duplicated genome carnivorous
plants have repurposed the enzyme to
digest insect exoskeletons which are
also made of chitin
typical plants also use their root
system to reach for and absorb nutrients
underground
in carnivorous plants these genes are
repurposed for their traps which are now
the primary nutrient absorber regular
plants also produce sweet nectar to
attract pollinators and now carnivorous
plants repurpose these nectar genes to
line the trap to attract their victims
then as the plants evolved to become
even better suited to their new niche
specific gene families were expanded
gene families that create digestive
enzymes for example became up-regulated
this allowed plants to fine-tune their
different carnivorous strategies
then once the plants were effectively
exploiting their new niche and absorbing
nutrients from living prey their
traditional leaves and roots were no
longer as necessary
many genes that were not involved in
carnivorous nutrition began to disappear
for instance aquatic water wheel plants
eventually lost their root system
altogether
as a result of losing many of these
typical plant genes the three plants
observed in the study are some of the
gene poorest plants to be sequenced to
date
meaning they have among the smallest
genomes ever discovered in plants
all carnivorous plants seem to have
followed this genetic road map to get to
where they are today
however surprisingly it was not a
genetic event that happened just once in
a single common ancestor belonging to
all carnivorous plants it's a sequence
of events that has happened several
times completely independently from one
another carnivory in plants has evolved
as many as six separate times some
carnivorous plants that even look nearly
identical turn out to be nowhere close
to each other on the evolutionary tree
both families of pitcher plants the
tropical genus and the north american
genus look almost exactly the same and
catch prey in the same exact way with
their deep slippery pitcher-shaped
leaves full of digestive enzymes
yet they became carnivorous at separate
moments in history on different branches
of the tree of life
these discoveries reveal something
surprising
most plants with leaves and roots
contain the material necessary to become
carnivorous
meaning the path to carnivory is open to
all plants
given the right circumstances in an
environment with little nitrogen and
with enough time some photosynthetic
plants we know today
can and likely will
evolve into brand new types of predatory
meat-eating plants the shapes they take
may be similar to the ones that exist
now
or new forms may come about altogether
plants are remarkable at adapting to
adverse conditions and only time will
tell which plants will eventually be
chowing down on their meaty neighbors
on this channel i talk a lot about
genetics and evolution and point to a
lot of phylogenetic trees
to me it's literally the coolest thing
ever to get a glimpse back in time to
understand when different organisms
diverged on the tree of life to see the
infinitely complex branches spreading
and unfolding over time
but it's understandable to ask how do
scientists know that stuff for years
scientists had only comparative anatomy
to go on darwin for example could only
look at the beaks of finches to observe
their differences and to attempt to
discern the different birds relatedness
and when comparing two organisms that
don't even look the same comparing
anatomy can't tell you that much about
their connectedness
so for a long time it was understandable
that people looked at the huge array of
life on earth and refused to believe it
was all related that every living
organism on this planet shares a common
ancestor but then came the discovery of
dna we can now see that all life does
look the same at the molecular level
meaning that all life shares a genetic
language and by comparing genetic
information it's possible to
quantitatively measure the relatedness
of organisms with data darwin couldn't
have ever dreamed of
and now with complex algorithms and data
analysis aided by massive computing
power the study of evolution and
genetics has never been more exciting
this is the field of computational
biology a field that uses computer
science to reconstruct genomes build
phylogenetic trees to look at
evolutionary relationships or unlock the
complex folded shapes of proteins in my
opinion it's the most important field of
research happening today and luckily
i've been able to get a solid overview
of it from the computational biology
course on brilliant the online stem
learning platform it takes what should
be a difficult subject and makes it into
a fun colorful and interactive set of
lessons and quizzes it's given me a
better understanding of how we know for
sure that natural selection is a
provable phenomenon
and gives me even more ammunition to
argue against the creationists that
always seem to flood my comment section
and to take your learning even further
brilliant has tons of interactive
courses on computer science and math
which dare i say are genuinely fun to do
the interactivity makes it easy to learn
and is something i wish existed when i
was in school the new year is a great
time for building new healthy habits and
there's no better place to channel that
energy than with brilliant i've
personally been adding a daily computer
science fundamentals lesson to my
routine after my daily wordle to get
started for free visit
brilliant.org real science or click on
the link in the description and the
first 200 people will get 20 off
brilliant's annual premium subscription
as always thanks for watching and if
you're looking for something else to
watch right now you can watch our
previous video why spider silk is
stronger than steel or real
engineering's latest video about the
reality of carbon taxes
you